right uh if I could have your attention
please then good evening to you all uh
members of this committee thank you for
joining us this evening we have a number
of uh officers from the council present
here this evening as well I thank each
one of you for coming to join us for the
part that you will play in our meeting
as it unfolds
um I think we have one or two members of
the public in as well you are also very
welcome as our other councilors who will
be speaking I am aware that to counter
the Yates wishes to speak under rule
20.1 for items four and five
care can also speak on item four under
20.1 please chair thank you
okay the first thing is I apologize for
the site delay we've had a slight
technical hitch counselor off
so I would I would like to speak as well
on
um after air 21 please item 21.
item which which item well 24 sorry
[Music]
and um
also chair I would like if you start the
meeting with a two-minute silence for
those people they lost their life in a
cross and channel Crossing thank you
first of all I'll uh Council more
your Committee Member so you you get the
right to speak in the debate what
normally happens with people speaking
under rule 20.1 is they speak before the
item
rather than after the item because then
they would be taking part in the debate
which is the purview of the panel at
least that is my understanding I'm sure
I'll be corrected as time moves along if
I've got that wrong but the first thing
I need to do are of course the safety
procedures
um so thank you everybody for coming if
the fire alarm is activated please
exit
via the main staircase opposite the list
in the foyer and assemble on Hawley
Square on the green officers will assist
us when it's deemed safe for us to
return to the chamber
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they're not used to make phone calls
or texts or Whatsapp during the course
of the meeting
now does anyone intend to film this
meeting
no I don't see any anyone intending to
film the meeting so we can just move on
a little bit forgive me this page is
jumping rather quickly
you are allowed to film the meeting if
you wish
our warning would normally be to advise
people not to film children and to
invite people who'd rather that their
facial features were not captured on
anything just filming just to advise
them that their faces may be captured so
they might need to look the other way
but you are very welcome was there
anything specific then that you wish to
film
item four
on the processing sector okay thank you
very much
I'm going to do this slowly
adjusting screen resolution
thank you
thank you very much
oh yeah
foreign
sorry chair um considering councilor
Ross
um
request
should I move a point of order to
request the minute silence or should
that be done before item four
that's on a sub on this committee I'm
not certain whether it should be now or
just before item before
I'm not sure there is a point of order
there but um for your information and we
would have got there in the end
the first and most important thing to do
while the fire safety regulations whilst
people are in the building once those
formal announcements have been made I
will exceed to counselor Ross request
and take a moment silence before we
begin the business of the meeting but in
my view it is most important to get the
safety
statements dealt with and out of the way
so that everybody in the room is aware
of what to do in case there is an
emergency thank you Jeff but thank you
sir
I have a list of members councilor Rolf
Council album counselor Yates who would
like to speak under items four and five
but I haven't had any requests from
members of the public
okay then we move then before we move to
the agenda items proper and number one
could I invite you we will pause for one
minute if members agree we'll have a
minute silence for those who are being
remembered particularly today from a
year ago in some very difficult times
thank you very much
I'd like to propose chair
thank you chair
um just firstly I want to thank um TDC
officers who have been to Monsoon Asylum
Center and who have had to intervene due
to the infectious diseases there I think
the work they've done to try and keep
um the residents and the staff there
safe is incredibly important and I want
to thank them on record for their work
secondly as someone who's hosted um uh
refugees in Margate in my home I just
want to promote Ken Refugee Action
Network and refugees at home as great
organizations who do work supporting
Asylum Seekers and refugees in Kent
um and that was that was it thank you
thank you very much Council Yates could
I ask a favor of you would you like to
communicate those details of those
organizations more broadly around to all
the members of the council so that we're
all aware of the existence of them happy
to even
console album
yes thank you chair
um
obviously this is uh the very emotive
subject
obviously it's very widely known about
what was happening in in the camp there
um with the very large amounts of
migrants being being held there all the
issues surrounding that
um I think sometimes uh what's got lost
uh amongst all of the news Etc it wasn't
much of it but I just wanted to speak on
on
behalf of the of the staff
the medical staff Etc who were looking
after the migrants in that camp and that
to suffer the same
horrible
situation there in relation to how they
how the migrants were actually put there
and live in and
as it's quite been been said by uh our
government it was a disgrace
and I think we have to recognize that uh
that it was a disgrace
and but I don't think enough's been said
about the people who work there who were
looking after uh the migrants uh I think
they've done it they've done a fantastic
job and it would have affected them
you know if you go in a place where it
is only supposed to be a thousand uh
1200 or so people and there's 4 000
there and you haven't got any more staff
to actually look after those people and
ensure that they are looked after Etc
then um you know I pay tribute to them
I'm pleased that the center is not being
used any anymore I don't think it was a
right I don't think it was the right
place
um whilst the government did have a plan
uh to only use up to for only about just
over a thousand migrants to be processed
there for one day
and then to be moved on
um
whether or not
the issues more migrants coming in etc
etc than they thought was going to
arrive
um
there was no after plan there was no
plan B you know so they had a plan a but
no plan Plan B so not having a plan Plan
B caused the issue that that was
happening there
um so I just wanted to make those points
uh chair and uh hopefully uh whatever we
decide to do as a council in relation to
the events that that took took place I
hope we can take all all of that on
board thank you chair
thank you councilor wolf
thank you chair and also thank you for
accepting my suggestion for two-minute
silence
um what I'd like to talk about today the
important things
related to this Council regarding the
immigration I know this is a national
issue and can be International as well
um
all the role and regulation that came up
in the past 23 years of my life in UK
as someone came as Asylum CK to this
country didn't stop people come
illegally to this country and I think
this Council should push the government
through that both our MPS to tell them
they need to set up their safe route to
stop the traffickers but make money and
bring people illegally to this country
no countries should allow illegal people
to get into their country thus to stop
in that only Can Happen by have a safe
route that can be a camp in France or
somewhere else instead to giving them 83
million pound to stop their people to
come to here I do not leave my house to
go to work and leave the door open and
pay my neighbor to look after my house I
shut my door and I will make sure nobody
will break into my house giving 83
million pounds over taxpayers and
upheaval to foreign countries to shut
your border is not going to work and
over a years traffickers have find
different way to come and I am sure if
there's a way to get better the
trafficker will find different way to
come here and menston Airport it was
built uh used that sent the fire Old
Fire Training Center was used for
um only 24 hours to people beholding
there but behind this Council were more
than
two three thousand people were holding
there so our job in this council is the
government do not do things behind our
back and rightly the leader of this
Council has spoke up when they try to
use the accommodation student
accommodation nobody bring that into the
council and I'm sure
the two MPS even they wasn't talking to
each other each one was given a
different message in the in the media
and I'm sure
um I'm not talking talking about
political party I'm talking about the
human being they were talking about the
people they were talking about the human
being trying to get to somewhere safe
but they were given two different
messages please let's make sure
immigration not be used for political or
election winning is not are being told
by people if you talk about immigration
too much you may not we not get back on
next time when a local election come do
you know what if that stopped me to
become a counselor I speak up for anyone
need to be a half go no voice and I
think this Council need to stand behind
the people and tell the government they
cannot behind them going to treat people
like what they did people died in there
and that is in under this this Council
area and I'm not gonna speak too much
because I know is
other people may want to say something
but is important we make sure through
both our MP we give this message to the
government they cannot behind this
Council to the dirty job thank you
thank you councilor off I appreciate the
position you come from I hope members of
the committee uh will uh note that as a
committee and as the committee chair
I've allowed Council of a considerable
amount of leeway on the subject that he
has talked about in relation to this
agenda item which is specifically about
the center but we understand the
position that you're coming from thank
you for speaking up on behalf of
generally of members of the public and
for being someone who has some direct
knowledge there is of course and I'm in
danger of sounding patronizing here and
I have no intention of doing that so
forgive me if it comes across like that
there is of course an element of Truth
in all of those things that have been
said but until we've really had a
presentation and an update on how things
and I haven't seen the update yet so my
ears will be fresh to it as fresh as
yours but members do please know it is
obviously a contentious issue and any
debate or discussion or questions that
follow from this report we are going to
have to control the meeting otherwise it
could go on forever so
I'm going to ask our presenters to begin
the presentation for us and then in the
first instance I will be going to
councilor King
uh to
perhaps repeat exactly what her
questions were for coming on to the
agenda item and then in the first
instance restrict questions to one
question per panel member to start with
so we can get around the panel and deal
with questions as they come up I don't
wish to be too Draconian with the time
but we do have a very large agenda that
we need to get through so with that in
mind and our thanks to the three
councilors who have spoken under rule uh
20.1 we now turn to the substance of
agenda item number four
a briefing on the Mansion processing
center and its effect on the local area
I'll call I believe First I'm calling
the leader or the chief executive
I'm actually going to
um briefly so my first point of call
then is to counselor Ashby the leader of
the council thank you very much Council
Ashman
thank you chair and uh thank you
overview and scrutiny for bringing this
matter
uh councilor Keen for asking for an
update
the council was first informed in
December 2021 that a processing center
for Asylum Seekers was to be set up by
the home office at the mod site at
manston
the basis of its operations was we
understood at the time to provide a
temporary staging point for Asylum
Seekers prior to them being placed
Elsewhere on a more permanent basis the
target set by the home office was that
no individual should need to stay Beyond
24 hours
I was asked to attend a meeting with the
permanent secretary on the 13th of
December which was the first
notification to us of such a plan
as a result I convene an urgent informal
cabinet meeting to discuss the position
that evening
as a result I wrote to the Home
Secretary pretty Patel previous Home
Secretary apriti Patel on the 15th of
December 2021 to express my concerns
grave concerns on my ad about the
suitability of the site and the prospect
of expanding Beyond its initial scope
no reply was received to that letter
from the Home Secretary
recent reports suggest that the Home
Secretary has since last December been
advised by civil servants of legal
difficulties in failing to provide
alternative accommodation to manston
the site is managed entirely by the home
office or its agents not only does TDC
have no role in its management but we
are not kept informed of how it operates
and for how long that will be or the
number of occupants at any one time
the only occasion on which we have been
asked or had the powers to inspect the
facility was when an environmental
health department was requested that are
sorry our Environmental Health
Department was requested by UK HSA to
visit the manston site and carry out an
inspection which took place on Friday
the 9th of September 2022
in early November reports emerged in the
media that the site was working Beyond
its planned capacity
those figures appeared to be four
thousand amongst the target maximum
Target of 1600.
as a result of that the home office
apparently put in place an arrangement
whereby their agent Clearspring were
funded to take leases on accommodation
in Kent and elsewhere in the country to
move Asylum Seekers as rapidly as
possible out of the mountain mountain
Center
TDC and other affected councils were
given no notice of this operation nor
given any notice of hotels or other
facilities that were being leased
I was a signatory to a letter to the
Home Secretary from all Kent leaders
setting out the very detrimental effects
that these Arrangements were having on
the county and the district services
the local MPS also made clear to the
Home Secretary that objections to the
use of the local accommodation without
advance notice
we believe that as a result of all these
objections accommodation in thanet was
stood down by Clear Springs notably the
accommodation the old Christchurch
accommodation unit up at um Northwood
the immigration Minister Robert generic
took part in a webinar with Kent leaders
and chief execs last week in which he
acknowledged that the situation had not
been well handled
he stressed that the home office was
seeking to rapidly reduce numbers at
Manson to avoid the overcrowding
placements taking place in Kent and that
councils would be given 24 hours notice
of any placements in that area
to date we have received no
notifications
news reports from the 22nd of November
suggests that the Manson Center is
currently empty pending any new influx
of Asylum Seekers
that is where we are up to with our
knowledge today chair thank you
we'll try to share but I'll happily
answer questions over and then come my
way
thank you pardon I should have put the
microphone on thank you we've had the
report
um
not only about Manson but also an update
on the events that took place over that
weekend uh just off Northwood Road the
old University Building
which I think did catch a lot of people
uh by surprise thank you for the update
for now I'm going to turn to councilor
Keane please would you like to
uh
ask
your question
thank you since I submitted this item
obviously things have really moved along
so a lot of what I was concerned about
at the time isn't directly relevant now
it was a shame not to have previous
foresight of the briefing because then
I'd have been better prepared for where
we are now some of the issues that I
wanted to ask about tonight is still
please forgive me if I interrupt you can
I encourage you though nevertheless to
answer them because our understanding is
that the center is empty being deep
cleaned pending any further use so it
might be I don't know I haven't seen
your questions but it might be that they
become relevant should they use the site
okay and I hope you don't mind me
interrupting nope that's fine thank you
um so as I say you know some of the
things have been covered in this but I
take your point that they might arise
again and indeed that was one of my
questions that the reports have been
that it is empty but is it still going
to be used in future
um and if so then yes all the points I
raised are just as relevant for any
future use unless we have an assurance
that it's not going to be used in future
um one of the things that seemed to go
really wrong was the communication
between central government and thanet
District Council which you've just
explained and explained all the issues
of things that you raised to move this
forward because that was going to be
another of my questions you know what
can we do to make this better if it is
used again or if other areas in thanet
are used again then what can we do to
improve the communication you've said
about the 24 hours notice but if we
don't get that and even so 24 hours is
not a long time to really think about
what the issues might be for anybody
being placed in the area
um
sorry
[Music]
when it was inspected and you've kind of
given the day at councilor Ashby
um by environmental health
were there no issues that arose from
that inspection because obviously
numbers were increasing there that we
didn't know about at the time and just
the overcrowding was a recipe for
disaster in terms of infection control
and infectious diseases and exactly that
happened
um
whatever was going on there it seems to
me it you know with the numbers and that
there was inadequate infection
prevention measures and therefore for
any future placements are these being
improved or are our inspection of them
you know making sure that they meet an
acceptable standard
and I mean a lot of my concerns were
about the infectious diseases and the
risk that posed both both to people in
the center but also to staff as
councilor Wolfe had pointed out and
people locally because infectious
diseases spread and that was a big issue
so I think that is my questions now
thank you
thank you indeed I wrote down please let
me know if I missed anything future use
communication failures
safety issues
um
and the health inspections
um
Nida would you like to deal with those
please and could I just add a little
to that did we do we have any further
information on the health status of the
man who died before he arrived
thank you chair well in answer to your
question to that no we don't
um I understand it's still undergoing an
investigation but um it the information
is not available to us or hasn't been
made available to this Council
the reopening of the processing center
um that has not been confirmed either
way
um the information is as up to date as
what I have it
um it hasn't been confirmed by Robert
generic whether or not it will be
um stood down at the moment it has not
been stood down so it is undergoing as
as we know
some adjustments to the actual site
um
so I can't answer that but as soon as I
know
um I understand that um sir Roger Gale
the MP for for that area
um is in regular contact with Robert
genre and as I say we had the webinar
and um I've never been one not to stand
and make a speech and I didn't withhold
my comments on that day I make no
excuses for our government I think this
is absolutely appalling situation and
um I can honestly say that all we we've
done is we've taken a very robust stance
but the home office is a very powerful
body and all we can keep doing is making
comment which we will um Robert generic
has listened very closely
so um
your second question was assurances of
other sites he has made a direct pledge
that no sites
will be considered well they could be
considered but no sites will be moved
into or utilized without 20 at least 24
hours notice to this Council of which
time we've obviously got time then to to
make comment
um but what we must remember is we can't
when we're mixing two situations up the
sites that
um the that was that was um chosen up at
the old Christchurch
um
uh College um campus was selected by a
contractor that was employed by the home
office to find sites as I say we didn't
have any knowledge about it at all
and that is part of what they're calling
the dispersal program which is nothing
to do with the manston processing center
so there's two there's two entities
going on here so the home office
appointed Clear Springs
for the south in of England and Wales to
find suitable locations which we'd
already objected to because we'd already
had a discussions with the housing team
that it would have an adverse effect on
us finding availability for
accommodation that letter that's what
prompted the letter to the Kent leaders
to um the Secretary of State and
that then
escalated because of the situation of
what happened in Dover the terrible
incident in Dover which then resulted in
everything escalating up so it all sort
of came to a head at the same time but
we're very aware that this dispersal
program will have an adverse effect on
our ability to be able to find
affordable rents for for our own you
know emergency housing situations so
we can have his Assurance so if anything
does happen then we have got a direct
line to start jumping up and down so we
we had that Assurance the chief
executive and myself from that meeting
that we had on Friday
the issues with inspection
um that came under Penny's team and
thankfully Penny's here tonight because
we we don't obviously have access to
that type of information but um Penny
will try and assist you with that
question thank you penny
so the inspection was a Food hygiene
inspection which literally is looking at
the
source of the food so it was a hygiene
of the premises and we worked with the
UK HSA so that's what was public health
for those of us that have been around a
while and they take the lead on the
Infectious Disease Control and pass all
of the information back to the site
operators
um which includes home office so all the
information was fed back at that time
what they needed to do to make the site
um
more
under control for infection under the
Infectious Disease Control so that they
could stop the spread of anything if
they happened so all that was fed back
at the time
Mr Carmichael thank you
a couple of things first we'll just to
emphasize I think the leaders already
probably made this clear but just want
to to to emphasize that the 24 hours
notice doesn't give us the ability to
refuse
a hotel being used is giving us notice
um it would allow us for example as was
the case in broadstairs in the at the
campus to point out that what Clear
Springs were doing was in breach of
planning
but we would then have to take planning
enforcement if clears brings them with
ahead and place people in the
accommodation so
notice is good and it's the right thing
for the government to do but we would
have to take any action if any action
was able to be taken on the basis of you
know proper grounds planning being
probably the main one
um the other probable point to make
about this is in the home office and Mr
generate made this clear on the webinar
we've got a number of migration schemes
for the country we've got the Afghan
refugees the Syrian refugees Ukrainian
refugees and the broader migration and
each of them is being organized in a
different way which is quite confusing
to say the least for councils and for
the general public we're trying to react
to them all I think is one of the issues
that migration will happen a place will
need to be found for the migrants
it was the organization of the Madison
Center which appeared to be the problem
and it was a combination of that and the
lack of only available resources for
people to move into or accommodation for
people to move into coupled with the
fact that I gather in October and
November the weather is particularly
good for crossing the channel and so a
larger number of people came over and
there was a bulge of manston which has
now been flattened out and people have
been moved on but I think Bob you're at
a meeting yes stay where you it was
suggested at least that manston would
not be stood down and we were just
waiting for new migration to come in is
that right
yeah
um it was a meeting that was led by
folks in a high District Council
um
inviting representatives from the home
office and partners to talk about some
of these issues and there was a
representative from the home office
involved in the management of the
manston processing center that I had a
conversation with and a clip from that
conversation the
um it the information I got for that
conversation was that the
um there happened to be no
um refugees or Asylum Seekers at the
center at the moment but it hadn't been
stood down by the home office and if
there are further arrivals then then
they would continue to use the center so
um that from that conversation that was
the understanding that I had
foreign
thank you very much Council Akeem
[Music]
I mean you know sort of it's uh
disappointing to hear that the center
hasn't been stood down
um completely because it doesn't seem
the right place uh to to manage
migration to me I do appreciate the
pressure it causes on temporary
accommodation in the area generally so I
think that's another Point uh to bear in
mind but I also
so from that where people have been
dispersed to is that within Kent or
further afield or don't we know
so far as we know again don't forget
we're not getting notifications so it's
not necessarily the case that the
council would know
um but I've been in touch with Chief of
techs and other councils and we've had
no notifications so we think for now
that what's happening is dispersal
Beyond Kent into other parts of the
country and the immigration Minister was
reasonably clear when he spoke to us
that that was his preference but that
will depend on numbers and the pressure
on the center at the time I think for
now uh placements are outside Kent
thank you very much
that's a whitehead
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Ashby and all the officers who've
contributed and my contribution is based
mostly around the issues that have been
appearing within the community and if
the center isn't stood down that we are
likely to experience again
due to a standard publishing convention
I'm currently looking at an agenda pack
that contains no item number no
information and no briefing outline
and that to me feels like an
accidentally perfect metaphor for this
entire situation
an invisible spot with no information
given or forthcoming and a determination
from central government to keep it
invisible and away from scrutiny
over the past few weeks I have spent a
significant amount of time on social
media doing my best to counteract
constant misinformation scare mongering
and racism especially in relation to
housing
as a council we are bound to our public
sector of quality duties which to
summarize require that in the exercise
of our functions we have due regard to
the need to eliminate unlawful
discrimination harassment and
victimization and other conduct
prohibited by the equality Act
Advance equality of opportunity between
people who share a protected
characteristic and those who do not
and Foster good relations between people
who share a protected characteristic and
those who do not
the management of immigration at a
central level as we've been discussing
undermines all of those duties and in
turn undermines our ability to uphold
them to a level that we can should and
will adhere to as a council
the persistent focus on private delivery
within housing policy at a central level
and the constant reduction in funding
for Council and affordable housing and a
Reliance on private development to
deliver affordable housing leaves our
most vulnerable residents without
reliable shelter the most basic of
requirements in society
it means that we currently have over 200
families in emergency accommodation many
out of area
we all know exactly where you stand and
you are to be admired for that but
please this is about the manston center
and it is about because we've linked
them for the purpose of this meeting the
short episode that took place at the
previous University I realize people
will have wider General thoughts on the
matter but please can we stick to the
agenda item of course I am going to
explain how they're linked
that determination to reduce cancer
housing and minimize State contribution
to welfare has left us without housing
stock that lack leaves us without the
resources to provide high quality
accommodation for anyone in need and I
emphasize anyone because everyone under
our care deserves high quality housing
from the moment that this idea was
mooted everyone involved at a strategic
level informed central government that
there could be no hope a suitable
accommodation at manston
and the woeful mismanagement of
immigration policy and Asylum claims
overall led to what should have been no
more than 24-hour stays turning into
weeks in entirely unsuitable conditions
when we first tried to bring this to
scrutiny it was argued that it wasn't
within our remit to do so as what has
unfolded here as a central government
function not a council function
unfortunately that's not how government
works
all of this is interlinked and a failure
at the highest levels create struggles
at all levels of government
our legal duty to Foster good relations
is damaged when residents are told that
we have in effect lost accommodation to
refugees when they haven't and when a
central policy of funding private
companies rather than councils to
provide housing produces unsurprisingly
absolutely no transparency or
communication between essential layers
of government the Whitehead is there a
question in here please
uh you really are straying off the topic
and this subject I'm sorry to disagree
with you but it has not been brought to
overview in scrutiny your previous
subject has been but this is a very
tenuous Link in my opinion at best I
must ask you to ask a question in
relation to the briefing that we've had
or please quickly conclude your remarks
thank you very much
sorry as overview in scrutiny isn't
simply our role to ask questions
and the things that I've been
experiencing
is related to turn into a public route
but there is an agenda item concerning
the use of the manston center and it has
been linked to the short-term temporary
use at Northwood Road where the
university building was taken over for a
couple of days I really must ask you to
stick to the agenda item you would not
in any Council committee be able to Veer
so far off the subject of an agenda item
uh for for any reason and and I'm only
asking you to be fair and stick to the
gender item we are well aware of your
opinion of uh government and County
Council and District local councils
failings in housing we are well aware of
that but that's not the topic
on this agenda item so again I must
please ask you to wrap it up or do you
have a question for the leader or for
the chief executive who are here to
answer I am more than happy to wrap it
up because I could have been finished by
this point and nothing I have said has
not already been said by the leader
foreign
for your contributions
um no I'm ready to wrap up thank you all
right okay
a legal duty to advance equality of
opportunity between people who share a
protected characteristic and those who
do not is damaged when discriminatory
Central policies that attempt to portray
entirely legalist item claims is illegal
create conflict and damage and embold in
some of the most unpleasant parts of our
political history and discourse
this isn't and has never been enough and
them issue it has never been a matter of
competition or resources being taken
away
the simple fact is that none of us are
being looked after
I am beyond glad that the Manson
facilities now apparently as empty as
this published portion of the agenda
and I hope with all my heart and I
understand clearly from cancer Ashby's
contribution that we will continue to do
our best to upholder our quality duties
and unite as a council when Central
failings undermine the health and safety
of all of those in our care
thank you chair
thank you very much
anything either of you wanted to come
back on on those comments at points
leader
thank you chair
um I'd just like to reiterate again that
um I have no bias in any of this my my
duty as a leader of the council is to do
the best I can for the residents of of
this district and I will continue to
point out the failings of this
government be on the processing center
be on housing be it on planning be on
anything that is that is my job as
leader of the council so
um I just would like to reassure you
that we've taken a robust stance on this
and we will continue to take a robust
stance on this but
um you know the as I said earlier the
home office are a very powerful body and
all we can do is point out where we
believe they're going wrong and I can
also
um
informed that the fact that we've had
two MPS stand up in the Commons and also
point out matters to it
um I am more confident with Robert
generic he does appear to be genuinely
making a huge effort to try and at least
relieve the situation so we can the
proof will be in the pudding we will see
where we go from here and as soon as we
we get information then it can be
relayed through to members in whichever
form that we can do that so um but I
want everyone to know that this isn't a
political stance this is um you know I'm
doing it because it is the right thing
to do and
um it is a very robust dance and you
know we will spell it out as much as we
can do but it is somewhat your hands are
somewhat tired when you're dealing with
this they have a a massive problem I
just wish that I could find the answers
for them and then I would tell them what
that was as well but we can only do our
best for our district
and that's what we're doing thank you
chair
you very much
thank you Council early
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Ashby just on what you were saying there
to what extent are directly rmps helping
you push that robust position
um
yeah that's it
um well speaking um about Sir Roger Gale
um when
I wrote or when we first were in when I
was first informed I was rung up
quite abruptly
um by the permanent secretary's
assistant and said you're to go on to a
zoom meeting on this was the 13th of
December and that was the first I heard
about it
immediately I got on the phone to Sir
Roger Gale who took the matter up and
and raised it in the Commons the next
day
because it's obviously was it was a
terrible decision and it was made
completely outside of the district's
knowledge
um and my letter which I'm quite happy
to publish
um if if members would like to see that
which was a letter dated the 15th of
December 2021.
and
um the MPS
um I know that sir Roger GAO has been on
the phone literally every day to Robert
generic since he was appointed as
Minister for
um immigration so
um and I know that Craig McKinley fought
very hard to make the point regarding
the Clear Springs
um
uh if you like The Taking of that that
property so I would imagine that the
pressure that they were feeling from all
of that was the reason why maybe
um that particular accommodation block
was stood down we don't exactly know why
it was stood down but I would imagine
that had a lot to do with it so both MPS
have been very very supportive and
um they had made voices very clear and I
think you can actually evidence that if
you watch live politics or you have any
playbacks on it so I can say that
they've been very supportive and I thank
them for that because it's me against
the home office is quite a tough call
even though they don't scare me thank
you Cher
thank you very much
um and and with regard in particular to
um the Northwood situation
um I can confirm that neither of our MPS
knew anything about it I know that
because I asked them
um I was also on the site before nine
o'clock in the morning on the Saturday
morning speaking to refugees speaking to
the head of security
and I wasn't backwarding coming forward
in telling him the security was
non-existent and speaking to the area
manager for Clear Springs homes
um
as far as I've been able to receive the
information I have no reason to doubt
the words of our MPS there was no
knowledge about what Clear Springs were
doing in that particular building at all
I don't wish to spread alarm and
despondency but the people that were
occupying that building were not from
the manston processing center they'd
come down from Hemel Hempstead and
they've been brought down very late at
night because they had to be moved which
links us to in the leader's presentation
what the leader has called the dispersal
program so there are two separate issues
here there's the initial dealing with
migrants when they arrive on our Shores
and then the continuing dispersal
program
um I think our leader uh
as well as our MPS and officers of this
Council acted very very quickly on the
Northwood situation and the matter was
resolved within 48 or 60 hours that
matter
was resolved we don't know the precise
details of
how it was resolved but we know it's
been resolved
um
thank you for the depth that you've been
able to go into and the information
you've been able to bring to the panel
thus far about both the issues I'm just
going to now go to first of all
councilor wing
Council fellows councilor Keane and
cancerous
we were on our back feet foot in a sense
and I I believe and hope that as a
council we fully apply and believe in
the principles of fairness equality and
human dignity and that that that means
in the way we treat everybody
it's on our patch this uh it's
particularly poignant for us in central
Harbor because we have on the occasion
seen those boats come into our Harbor
Trisha saw one coming to the main Sands
and it's harrowing to see fellow human
beings our brothers and sisters uh
traveling across that that piece of
water which is incredibly dangerous
nobody in their right mind would get in
a rubber dinghy basically with an engine
and come across there
I I we should not and we cannot remain
silent on this issue and I I I I don't
think we can because this situation is
going to continue we need to look at why
the the center was put there in the
first place because if we managed to
shut our Center down there's just going
to be another Center that's going to be
just as bad on somebody else's patch
interestingly the 81 of people who seek
asylum in this country their claims are
approved
so 81 of those people that are coming
across those boats on those flimsy boats
coming across that water women and
children and young men
eventually their claims are approved
they have a legal right to be in this
country
and it's shocking that we force people
who have a legal right to come to this
country because of situation in their
own country that we force those people
to go through that situation and I want
to quote from it was the uh it was Tim
louton atori MP
he said
I am a 16 year old orphan from an East
African country escaping a war zone and
religious persecution and I have
siblings legally in the UK at the moment
what is the safe and legal route for me
to come to the you crack UK Sue Ella
bravaman couldn't answer that question
and this is that the root cause of why
we have to have that Manson I can't call
it a processing center I can't even use
the word dispersal we're not dealing
with carrots that come on a flight from
wherever that need to be processed and
dispersed we're dealing with human
beings human beings who have 81 of them
according to the government's own
statistics have a legal right to be in
this country
I would like and it is quite interesting
that there's a number of systems so my
central Harbor uh Council as we set up
uh regular meetings with our Ukrainian
friends uh they're here
they're settled they're working they're
working most of them their kids are in
school and it is quite interesting that
this government has decided there's a
bit of an apartheid system going on in
how certain certain people are dealt
with in a much different way which has
less of an impact on us as a community
that the vast majority of immigrants
that have entered this country recently
are ukrainians and people from Hong Kong
you know the the scaremongering that
we're being invaded is another narrative
that I find quite offensive uh that's
being used by the media and also by the
government I'm afraid to say and I'm
quite disappointed with if you like that
the labor leader saying he wants to deal
with immigration as well uh so I guess
what I'm trying to say is
that Center is going to remain there
because we are still going to have
people coming across in boats and what
we actually need to petition our
government to do is to provide a safe
route for 81 of people who've got legal
right to be here to be processed I don't
like that word I believe the French
offered to build a site on the other
side and our government said no we need
that to happen we need that to happen
for two reasons we need to stop people
coming across in flimsy little boats
coming across our Shores we need to shut
down the processing and the dispersal
centers and we need to make sure that in
doing so we can tackle the people that
the the 19 that shouldn't be here and
actually that the traffickers that are
making a great deal of money out of this
so I would urge us as a council to
petition the government in whatever way
we can to open up safe routes which
would then mean that that process center
is not required for use thank you
yeah thank you chair I just wanted to
ask um if we know if Clear Springs still
have an association with the university
buildings was that ended now if so if
it's ended does that mean our leader has
the green light to go ahead with her
plans that were well publicized and also
you talked about it didn't have the
appropriate plan in the University does
that do we know what the if the mod had
the quick planning at manston
to house the sign of sneakers out
um there's a few parts to that question
isn't there
um so firstly we are in contact with the
owners
um at the University Building
um the the exact
um status of the agreement that uh
clearsberg has had with the owners we're
not entirely clear about that but we do
understand that they don't have any
intention to use it again
um in terms of planning
um in relation to the mountain sector
when the menston center we're not aware
of any planning processes that have been
followed in relation to that facility so
but we do
the advice that we've had
and we are going to investigate this a
bit further is that the home office
would be able to continue to use that
until sometime next year when they would
at that point then need to
um
obtain some kind of planning approval
for their use of that site
um that doesn't necessarily have to come
through us though it could be determined
at a county or a national level so it's
not necessarily an application that
comes here but at some point
the planning issues that manston
wouldn't need to be resolved
foreign
[Music]
thank you there's been a lot of concern
I mean both you know in the local area
both for the migrants and a lot of
misinformation which have created some
bad feeling and can the council issue a
statement updating the public on what
has happened and our concern for how
things have been thinking
later
did you want to take that one or Mr
Carmichael
um I can take it to the chair if that's
okay I was just looking at um I mean no
doubt this this meeting is being live
streamed so
um I would imagine that a lot of the
information that we've been talking
about is we're already out there but I'm
more than happy to work with Hannah to
produce uh if you like an outline of
what what we've been talking about
tonight
um and make a publication I mean we have
to understand that we can't give out
facts because we're not in control of
the facts so we have to be very careful
about
overstating anything that is actually
come falls under the the home office's
area so um but I'm sure that I can turn
around and ask Hannah whether or not we
can we can draw an outline on that
I'm happy to respond yeah we've had a
couple of um or quite a few press
inquiries over the last few weeks and we
have as far as possible tried to make
our position clear
um what we haven't done is issue kind of
a general broader statement which I'm
sure we could do and put on our website
so the position is kind of clear for
anybody to see at any time I'm sure
that's something we could arrange to do
thank you very much and finally then
Council Austin
thank you chair I just wanted to restate
some of the comments that have been made
about how this is our government's mess
up and their their failure to liaise
with us as a council to work more
generally with councils as counselor
Whitehead has highlighted to work with
the French government to set up a
processing center on the opposite side
of the channel to allow migrants to but
who have been processed inverted commas
to work when we've got a situation here
where we've got jobs vacant and we're
considering changing our immigration
rules in order to allow more people in
and yet we have people here who are
desperate to work many of whom go
through years and years before their
Asylum claim is properly processed and
in the meanwhile suffer from physical
and mental ill health partly as a result
of not having the chance to work and
having to be housed in a hotel that
somebody else's expense the whole system
is completely crazy
the one thing I would want to say and
and this is this may be the only time
that anybody in this room hears me say
this I wish to pay tribute to Sir Roger
Gale and Sir Roger Gale's office they
have been superb I uh he has been in and
out of that Center he has kept people
informed his office have taken in uh a
variety of donations that he's been
allowed to take in and I gathered from
councilor Cup yesterday when we were
planting trees together uh that um the
office that used to be councilor cups is
now full to the gunnels with donations
that aren't necessarily going to go into
that center now but they're going to go
elsewhere for people in need so I I
would like to say thank you to Sir Roger
and I would urge our MPS and it's sad
that neither of them is here this
evening to continue to put pressure on
Mr generic and the government to work
with local authorities because otherwise
we're going to keep doing this and it's
not going to be to the benefit of our
existing residents our new residents or
anybody else I thank you
thank you very much I ought also to uh
offer our thanks to both our MPS we
moved the date of this meeting as you
know because there was compulsory voting
taking place on Tuesday in London
um
unfortunately sir Roger was not able to
attend this alternative date at all but
my understanding is he has been very
busy with the leader and the chief
executive uh
and Craig McKinley uh fully intended to
be at this meeting this evening to
answer any questions that people had but
at very short notice he is not available
but they are as as you have said they
are involved
um although no definitive answers came
out of the weekend at Northwood uh by 9
30 on a Saturday morning I was in touch
with him and he made several calls he
spoke with the leader he spoke with all
sorts of people including sir Roger Gale
and Robert generic to try and find out
what was happening with this dispersal
program and I think that's one of the
things that's come out of it is that
there's got to be more stringent control
on the dispersal program it's no good we
may not like the title but that's what
it is it's no good simply
allowing these people to move migrants
around the country almost at will so it
I'm sure it's going to be monitored uh
much better than it has been hitherto
thank you everybody for the
contributions uh the agenda item has now
run for 40 minutes and I really think
um
unless there is a constitutional reason
why I can't wrap it up I think I would
like to wrap up this agenda item now is
that okay yeah that's absolutely fine
too thank you for the questions and the
contributions I'll catch up with you
later Council right
um
thank you for all the contributions
um and at this point I would like to
invite anyone who does not need to
remain here for the rest of our agenda
to take a moment and leave the chamber
if you would like to
we may as well adjourn for a three or
four minute Comfort break if it's
required and then we will reconvene at
quarter past eight
foreign
members thank you very much and thank
you again for all your contributions
um I'm going to reconvene the meeting
now so ask them to speak to uh put the
microphones on so that though people who
have been able to watch us moving around
the room they haven't been able to hear
us but they will now uh as soon as I'm
advised they will be able to hear the
meeting continuing
are we are we on thank you very much
thank you for that short break we're now
going to look at Agenda item number five
the decarbonization of the council's
housing stock
councilor Yates
would like to speak thank you Council
Yates thank you
um it's a very short comment um but I
believe that the housing team have just
submitted a um the social housing
decarbonization bid for round 2.1
um which is a bid for 4.3 million pounds
for five tower blocks in thanet
um with four Loft floor and external
wall insulation amongst other things
and I just want to say thank you to the
hard-working officers involved
because this is both essential work for
our residents and especially in this
energy crisis but also to fight climate
change and reduce our energy usage
So yeah thank you to the officers
involved
yes thank you very much
um
Samuel Sullivan
I can't see you there you are
if I can hand over to you now please to
present any further parts of the report
thank you chair
um so um our journey to Net Zero this is
our this is the strategy for how the
tenant and silly solder services will
reduce greenhouse gas emission to ensure
the HRA housing stocks support the
government's aims for decarbonisation
and meet Net Zero by 2050. it also links
into the council's Net Zero strategy
the strategy is especially important
because of the way it affects our
tenants many of whom are in fuel poverty
and this is for three reasons
we will reduce fuel consumption for our
residents making their homes warmer and
more comfortable using less energy
the work we carry out will be highly
disruptive and residents will have to
learn how to live in different ways or
use new technologies
the new build properties that come into
the social housing stock will already be
high performing and our officers will
need to ensure they can show tenants how
to make the most of them
this document does touch upon the
expectation of the performance of new
bills but its main focus is on the
current stock that is poorly performing
firstly examines the data that we have
and what we must do and to enhance what
we know
about our properties
we know that we don't have very good
data for which we have a plan to improve
and this underpins our efforts and helps
us to prioritize our properties for
retrofitting we have three objectives
and these are to get all properties to
EPCC by 2030 reduce energy consumption
for residents and offset carbon
emissions
to achieve these objectives we have
three principles to work by
tackle our worst performing properties
first
um have a fabric first and no regrets
and this means we'll ensure that our
homes are well insulated first as this
will have an immediate impact on the
resonance fuel consumption once this is
in place we're in a better position to
find clean heat solution that
complements the building thus we have no
regrets on what we have already done and
have to redo any previous work and for
us to have meaningful resident
involvement
it's predicted that it'll cost the
council around 40 million to achieve the
Net Zero Target with a further 4 million
for professional fees therefore we want
to tap into as much funding as possible
and are currently exploring such routes
as social housing decarb fund eco4
local Authority delivery scheme and home
upgrade Grant
this document gives more detailed
breakdown on budget set on various
measures and this includes the 12.3
million pounds for our tail blocks
we also know that we have to act now to
achieve our targets and we have an
opportunity to apply for funding in the
social housing decop fund Annex 2
and this is our bid and delivery to
social housing decar fund wave 2.1 gives
further information on what our plans
are and to make a start on the work that
we need to do the headline is as Council
Yates has pointed out that we did get an
application in in time for around 4
million and this will need to be match
funded by the council by a further 4
million
we've applied to carry out Works to our
five of our six towel blocks which will
achieve an EPCC and B in all properties
it's a highly ambitious project that
will include replacement of the external
wall insulation which is being funded by
homes England cyclical Works structural
works and fire safety works we estimate
the total value of this project being in
the region of 25 million
we've decided to start on the tower
blocks for a number of reasons
our trajectory pledges to complete a
full retrofit of our tail blocks by 2028
um they have suffered from a lack of
investment over the last 10 years
meaning they are our worst performing
properties not just for epcs but also
for anti-social behavior and complaints
they look tired and they're hard to be
kept clean now
we have been awarded pre-sender funding
for the replacement of the external wall
insulation and we must get on and
replace this to ensure we remain
eligible from the remainder of the
funding we have consulted homes England
and they are happy with the way we are
proceeding with this
a chosen bid and delivery route was for
the following reasons that we have no
one in our team with bid writing skills
or the capacity to complete the
requirements of the bid we need to
deliver the project by March 2025 or we
will have to pay back the awarded
funding therefore the appointment of a
bid and delivery partner fulfills both
criteria and gives the assurance that
bay is require to have the capacity to
deliver and the supply chain in place
as the tight turnaround time do not
allow for a full procurement exercise
Mia's approached us initially and
offered us this service and we decided
to go with them for a number of reasons
we already have a good relationship with
them they have a good knowledge of our
stock and residents especially our tire
blocks and they are highly complex
buildings
they were successful in securing funding
in wave one for other local authorities
and I've spoken to one of those local
authorities this gave me greater
confidence as they praised beers bid
writers and are pleased with the
progress they are making to deliver
against their commitments
we approached another provider and they
did not give us the same level as
commitment as me as did
we have found a route to procurement by
direct award through a framework and
have engaged a consultant that will
provide us with a value for Money Report
mirrors are working completely at risk
at the moment and we are now working on
our plan a and plan B for if we win the
bid or for if we don't win the bid what
is clear that even if we don't win the
social housing decal funding we still
need to press on replacing the external
wall insulation
if we do fill in the bid and we feel
quite confident we need to be ready to
award the contract and get on with the
work as the time scale for delivery is
so narrow
if anyone has any comments or questions
thank you very much indeed uh councilor
bayford did you have anything you wanted
to add at this point
uh nothing except to again thank Sally
and the team for very detailed and
transparent report and able to saw at
all to see
um what how we hope to meet our Net Zero
Zero
um
sorry
uh how we ha we hope to make me
um next zero within the time frame
um and to
to get as much money as we can
um
from from the bidding process and and
obviously
um
the the we're looking to be able to do
this in the most efficient way as
possible to it so there's as little cost
as
as possible as possible to come out of
our general funds but thank you very
much for a very very detailed report
thank you chair I'm just very quick
comment for me about the decision-making
process for this work
um so firstly the main purpose of this
report this stage is to present the
strategy
um to this meeting and to Cabinet in
December but also the second Annex gives
you an update on where we are with the
bid for wave
2.2.1 and the proposed Works to the
tower block so you know the direction of
travel for those things at this stage we
don't have the detailed scope of work
specifications for the tower blocks and
we're still waiting for some feedback
from some of our Consultants
particularly on the heating Solutions
um so we've engaged Specialists
Consultants to advise about those things
that the heating Solutions and other
aspects of the buildings for us when we
have got that detailed scope of works
and we'll then be bringing another
report to Cabinet seeking approval to
let the content back for those works so
this report's not actually asking for
that approval at this stage if you
wondered why that was
you know not included in the
recommendations but we will be bringing
another report once we've got those
scope Works finalized
thank you
uh just it's just a quickie really uh
but thank you I mean it's great that
we're going to be dealing with our worst
properties first and it just relates to
Harbor Towers so in Harbor Towers we
have a combination of tenants and also
owner occupiers will the owner occupiers
be be levied some sort of cost for their
portion of that or is it free to
everybody
it's not a straightforward answer I'm
afraid
um the um the the this program has got a
mixture of funding sources
um so the Holmes England funding for the
external wall insulation the primary
reason for government intervention uh in
with landlords to fund external wall
insulation replacement was to avoid
costs being passed on to leaseholders so
we're confident that that element of the
works
um assuming we do get the full Grant
from homes England for the external wall
insulation we're confident that that
won't that cost won't get passed on to
leaseholders
um the the other works
um then certainly The Works that the
council files directly from its program
um they they will those costs will need
to be shared with leaseholders and we
we've been through this scenario
previously with other buildings when the
legal advice is that actually it's not
legal for us to waive charges for
leaseholders and pass them on to tenants
effectively but we are seeking
alternative sources of funding to see if
some of those costs can be covered by
external funding so there are other
grants around to help owners with
insulation works and Energy Efficiency
work so we're going to try and support
those leaseholders accessing that
funding wherever we can to try and
minimize any recharges going back to
leaseholders
I have councilor Austin councilor
Whitehead Council Keane and councilor
Paul Moore in that order please
thank you chip I just wanted to say
thank you and well done and can I once
again point out the tenderness holder
Services as an exemplary uh team in
terms of the clarity transparency and
completeness of the information that
we've received I I would really like to
see information of this quality coming
through on all our major external bids
across the council it would be so
helpful to us as members but also I
think in terms of governance and
scrutiny this is a really really helpful
process so thank you
thank you chair
I've spoken on this in several forums
now so I will be brief which I'm sure
you will appreciate the cancer Piper
firstly I would like to congratulate
housing on putting this bid together at
a time of extraordinary stress
secondly I would also like to praise the
fabric first approach to energy saving
targets
in conversations with counselors in
several London boroughs with similar
housing stock in terms of age and fabric
the importance of insulation cannot be
overstated
introduction of future green
technologies is essential but with an
existing stock without the building
fabric to support newer Technologies
adequately we would not be using these
Technologies to their full advantage in
new builds we can
I've mentioned concerns in relation to
the Prosper framework previously
although I do understand its usage in
relation to the incredibly tight
turnarounds times central government
give on funding bids but I do welcome
the commitment within it to
apprenticeships and the use of local
contractors
19.2 percent of our households are now
facing fuel poverty
as the paper States however these
figures were compiled before we saw
projected energy bills rise to
4427 pounds in 2023
our strict definition of poverty is if
household income is 60 below the median
equivalized income after housing costs
and in thanet we have the double hit of
hyperinflation in the housing market
especially in some of our most deprived
worlds
in July than it already had a child
poverty rating of 33.1
percent in facing these dual challenges
there is no way that our situation will
not escalate far beyond this
I mentioned this because although we can
focus on our properties the greater
number of residents live in either
privately rented or privately owned
properties and they will face the same
or similar challenges and an uncertain
external Market
I know that we have measures in place to
tackle this part of our energy saving
and decarbonization approach so I was
wondering if it would be sensible and
prudent to discuss this as part of this
item to reassure residents that help
will be available across all areas
thank you very much
did you want to respond to that at this
point
um well one thing I can add to that is
that we did um take a paper to Cabinet
um
last week
um introducing a new Grant scheme to
support Energy Efficiency measures for
people on low incomes in the district
that were struggling to either improve
the installation of their home repair or
install new Energy Efficiency heating so
so there is funding around to support
that with that very issue and we've got
two officers in the housing service that
are dedicated to energy advice and
energy to support and accessing funding
for residents in the in the in the
private rented and the underoccupied
sectors and I should say they are
getting hundreds of calls from people
and only recently we've had to expand
the staff resource there to to cope with
that so there's clearly a demand out
there and the team is doing everything
they're going to support that
thank you very much
cancel the key
thank you a great piece of work so well
done to all involved
um in the report I was very surprised to
see that 33 of the housing stock have no
EPC rating now in in your report Sally
uh you did say about you knew the data
was bad and you know sort of you're
looking to improve that and I just
wondered about that particular figure
um
who who Who's responsible for doing
actually physically doing the EPC
um ratings for buildings and how come
this this whole tranche of information
is missing what can we do to improve
that because obviously that's a real
foundation for Energy Efficiency thank
you
so um we so this is kind of what we
inherited from East Kent housing the
data is uh very poor we've searched
through the National Database for EPC
information to check that we don't have
just dismissing documentation but it
seems that that we that we don't
um we have 60 000 pounds in this year's
budget to increase the L data
intelligence in this area and we've got
a contract in place now to start
carrying out epcs we have a data asset
officer who is as it's coming through
he's putting that information into our
system so that we can use that to inform
bids to and to inform our reporting
councilman yes thank you chair and uh
you've ruined my my questions because
um you brought me in last and someone
has stole my funder
my same question was regarding the epcs
epcs have been live since 2007. no legal
requirement for rental properties and
obviously we as a council are falling
short of that
you're quite right I did my basic sums
33 of roughly 3 000 houses to get an EPC
you're looking at 60k to get all those
epcs done it's going to be a little bit
more because I rounded down and I'm glad
to hear that we've got assessors that
are involved but could we not actually
get other people trained up to do that
because these courses are only 1300
pounds for five day course and then
you're qualified to do epcs and then we
could uh do our epcs in-house and we
wouldn't be paying external companies
large amounts of money to do that and we
would save ourselves that money so those
are my questions with EPC but Council of
King style my thunder and also I'd like
to reaffirm the sentiments from all my
committee members all the good work
you've done in producing this work and
the strategy thank you
[Music]
um well yeah I'm sorry there we go
um we we did do a bit of analysis to see
if it would be more efficient to put
have our own in-house EPC assessor and
actually for the time it takes to carry
out an a single EPC it is more cost
effective to Outsource which is why we
have done it that way
I can't remember the exact figures but
if you're interested I can certainly
find the data but we we did look into
that
just on my thunder there councilor more
she did because I was going to say if I
could ask Kevin look at that could I
just come back obviously because if we'd
had this information those three
thousand over the 15 years since these
the EPC has been required you've done
half an EPC every day so we need to get
it done because it's a legal requirement
very much and thank you to to Sally and
Bob and Jill for presenting the report
to us we are asked to note then the
journey to Net Zero and the bid and
delivery of shdf wave 2.1 and the other
items that we've shared as part of the
discussion thank you very much
we move now on to agenda item number six
same rules apply if there's anybody who
doesn't have to be here you're welcome
to leave us if you would like to
um agenda item
number six then is quarter one budget
monitoring report and Matt is here
instead of Chris Blundell so I invite
you Matt to
uh introduce the report for us
thank you chair
this is the first budget monitoring
report for this year taken which has
already been taken to cabinet on the
13th of October for consideration we're
forecasting Nova spend of just under 1.8
million against our general fund Revenue
budget one of the main factors causing
this overspend is the additional demands
in the housing service with more
homelessness placements in response to
this the council was reviewed and is
delivering its homelessness strategy
action plan we are regularly monitoring
the levels of homelessness and we are
recruiting more staff and commissioning
new services to address the increase in
Need for support
our financial pressures are detailed in
the report that include additional
agency Staffing requirements in the
waste and recycling service and also
higher gas and electricity costs
our general fund Capital program showing
a substantial under spend this is in
part due to the phasing and timing of a
number of Grant funded projects some of
which are recommended to be slipped into
later years of the program
in the HRA there is a marginal forecast
overspend of 119 000 against the revenue
budget whereas within our Capital
program we are proposing a number of
budget variations so that the profile of
our budget is close to closer match to
our revised expectations for the time in
the future spending
finally there are a number of budget
adjustments that are detailed within the
report which were recommended to council
for approval
that is effectively it and I invite any
questions if anybody's got any in
relation to the report if I can't answer
them now then I'll go away and come back
with them
foreign
thank you very much
um
members to uh councilor wing
it's to do with waste and recycling I do
I think we rely quite heavily on agency
staff anyway
are we trying and I think it's due to
availability of people basically are we
are we are we trying to investigate any
any sort of possible Alternatives around
growing our own staff so that we don't
rely on agency stuff
yes
um no we we've been within race and
recycling we've always relied heavily on
agency just because of the nature of the
business effectively if if a driver
doesn't turn up we have no choice but to
go to an agency and get a driver
um which is a good example because drive
drivers hdv drivers are putting huge
pressures on Service delivery just
because there's a shortage of HTTP
drivers across the country and elsewhere
in Europe
um what that effectively means is that
costs are going up in relation to SUV
some HUV drivers are running as much as
50 50 60 000 pounds a year as a local
Authority delivering a refuse surface
for example that's that's not a sort of
salary expectation we can meet but what
we have done is put in place
arrangements to allow us to retain and
recruit staff over that period
um moving forward we are looking at
opportunities and we're instigating a
training program so that if if members
of Staff internally have a driver's
license and interested in becoming an
hgv driver will support that training to
allow capacity moving forward and job
descriptions are effectively being
flexed to allow full cover around
driving so that we've got driver loaders
rather than just drivers or just loaders
so yes those things are being looked at
as part of that process
agency generally has been difficult
because although covid is seen to be
sort of drifted a little bit within
waste and recycling because the
proximity of staff to each other if you
have one member of a crew with covid you
end up with multiple members of a group
of covid and we went through a period
where we were carrying on average about
15 people off sick with with covid
during a period of period of time
for each of those 15 people that
requires an agency person to cover it
just for us to get out our basic service
but we are looking at opportunities to
create capacity moving forwards yes
members any other comments you'd like to
make
um I hope you will forgive me for this
but it is an area uh
close to my heart as it were
um I note the section about the
crematorium income
um
are there
any indications that the increasing cost
of gas for example
is going to seriously affect the price
of cremations are there any plans at
this stage to pass those increases onto
families or is the council going to have
to
uh take a hold of that itself for the
time being or are there any relief
systems available from government to
local authorities because it's a
necessary service that we have to do
and it does cost money
there is a huge impact across Council as
a result of utility increases gas and
and electric as part of the budget
strategy for 2223 we made sure we
factored in some capacity to deal with
the uncertainty around fuel increases
and this is what's being talked about in
terms of overspend is is reflective of
the fact that we've absorbed a large
chunk of those inflationary increases as
part of the strategy for 23 24 we're
also considering the impact of inflation
across our wider portfolio and we're
reviewing fees and charges there is a
link between inflation on staff and
other input costs to fees and charges
but the moment fees and charges
increases are in line with basic
inflation rather than
massive you know 40 increases as a
result of fuel so I would argue that as
an organization we are managing a large
chunk of that impact
not passing out
thank you very much thank you
Council Austin
thank you chair can I ask about the
income on the coastal projects income
from Southern water because it I'm I'm a
little concerned that this becomes like
uh Council of wings Ramsgate Town
Council Members Grant which has been
promised about 17 times to different
organizations my understanding was that
some of the money from Southern water
had been offered by the leader to town
councils to help with the renovation of
lifts and that some of those discussions
were ongoing is that not the case
my basic understanding was there was an
original Proposal with the when the
money was received for potential
projects associated with it nobody had
taken anything forward with regards to
the offers that had been made so there
was no acceptance of taking over the
lifts and the responsibilities
associated with the lifts in order to
take them forward because there's a
significant cost difference between the
amount required to do the lift up the
amount required to run them on a regular
basis and the amount of money that was
available
may I come back to
my understanding was that Ramsgate Town
Council in particular is still waiting
for information
in order to make a decision about that
so I don't know where we are with that
but
I can only take it away and inquire
further and then come back to you thank
you
thank you thank you everybody very much
thank you Matt for that we move then to
agenda item number seven uh call upon
Sally O'Sullivan to introduce the report
uh the housing estate strategy policy
and standards Sally
thank you
um so these are three quite closely
linked documents the strategy is our
vision that we have for our Estates and
it describes four objectives that we
believe will enhance our Estates as a
place to live
these are to promote Community improve
the estate appearance have better better
Vehicle Management and be a safer place
to live the strategy also describes how
we will approach our Estates to achieve
our objectives and how we will
prioritize our states for review and
Improvement works
an estate policy is a regulatory
requirement this estate the policy
applies the rules around how the
strategy objectives will be delivered it
also describes to Residents residents
and our responsibilities in achieving
that and finally the estate standards
lets our residents know what work we do
to maintain and take care of our
communal areas around in and around our
blocks of flats this includes communal
cleaning and how we deal with communal
repairs ground maintenance and car parks
it lets residents know what they are
responsible for which includes the
storage of belongings in communal areas
and the disposal of refuse and how we
monitor the standard in partnership with
our residents
residents were highly involved in the
development of these documents and we
used information gathered from our
estate inspections and benefited from
two resident focused groups as well
thank you
thank you very much members do you have
any questions
for Sally on this one
okay then we are asked to note the
report and to thank you very much for it
I didn't see you I beg your partner I
was looking but I didn't see you
councilweight
thank you
in general I'm in full support of the
outlined measures and I fully
acknowledge the work and effort that has
gone into these policies
in relation to recent enforcement of
estate strategies I do have a question
in relation to talk to enforcement in a
specific way
when bringing back in housing back
in-house one of my absolute priorities
and one of housing's absolute priorities
was having a tenant and leaseholder
group that genuinely felt like an equal
partner in housing provision who would
be listened to and who would help to
shape our policies
in our current implementation of the
talk policies I do believe we need to
consult with residents more widely
during covid due to social isolation the
growth and maintenance of gardens wall
hanging pots and patio plants and flats
was encouraged by central government to
benefit mental health and encourage
interest in sustainable growing
many of our residents and communal
blocks have had wall pots Flowers by
their door and equally a significant
number of our residents have health and
mental health issues that make these
measures not only a valued part of
community life but also a vital support
for the mental health of those residents
we all understand the importance of
removing anything that could restrict
access
however when visiting residents who
contacted me regarding this access even
by official Official Guidelines has not
been an issue but residents whose mental
health relies on these Gardens which
issue taught notices requiring them to
dispose of what were in some cases
long-standing wall Gardens within seven
days with no prior explanation of how
this policy would be enacted
I know that many residents did not
understand or agree with wall or railing
Gardens being defined as property and
communal areas and would not have viewed
or understood the policy in that way
for most of us picturing that policy in
action it's the idea of household
belongings that comes to mind not
balcony plants
it has caused significant distress to
some residents including some of those
that we view as Community Champions and
who are actively involved in their
blocks and communities
I asked when residents contacted me
about this whether we could look at a
different approach as has happened in
some London boroughs in terms of railing
Gardens or dispensations for secured
pots
but I've not yet had a written response
on this issue so I would like to ask for
further information on implementation of
this particular area of our talk process
now
I am fully supportive of all of
housing's efforts and commend these
policies as a whole
but resident involvement and consent is
key to building a secure future for our
housing and the communities it contains
so for those residents who were issued
with taught notices for their wall
Gardens would it be possible to have an
update on whether we can be more
flexible on Gardens long term thank you
thank you very much
thank you
um so
it in a nutshell unfortunately we can't
um these the reasons we had to bring the
taught notices into place is through the
fire safety act
um we have to employ someone to carry
out five risk assessments when these
assessments are carried out they tell us
what we need to do to be compliant and
that is a zero tolerance policy on
having anything kept in communal areas
um
we have tried to see if there's air
where we can be lenient with this but we
we cannot we there can't be any gray
areas we have to we have to implement
what we are told by our fire risk
assessors
um if we were to allow for certain
things to be kept in a communal area and
the worst was to happen
um we would then have to explain why we
didn't follow what we were told to do by
our own fire risk Assessor this is why
we do this
um so it's not an area that we can
consult our residents on whether how we
implement it or where we can be lenient
we have to follow what we are told to do
in the fire safety act we have to follow
what our
fire risk assessors as professionals
tell us to do
um what we have tried to do is given
good information
on talk notices and while we're doing it
and we provide that information through
our newsletters through the documents
and policies that we're producing now
and we also where there are taught
nurses is being issued we put letters
through everybody in that block to
explain what we're doing that they might
find a taught notice on their belongings
we put signs up as well
so if they don't see the letter through
their letterbox there'll be a sign up in
the hallway and also on those letters
there is a phone number for them to
contact if they are concerned on what
they need to do so that their items are
not removed and what we can do to help
them
so unfortunately there isn't anything
else that we can do on that due to fire
safety
thank you very much I do fully
understand the fire safety aspect I
think the confusion for residents is
that it's also been applied to things
that are external to the gangways and
outside the railings so it wouldn't
impede access so that was my query but
thank you
Mr Potter I just thought I wanted to say
that um you know we are aware that some
of our tenants in some of our blocks do
have
um a lack of storage space and you know
things like bikes and push chairs and
prams and
um you know we quite often find that
those sorts of items are in the communal
staircase which is also the means of
escape and so are officers are often
having to deal with that and telling
people they can't keep those things in
those areas
where we are aware of
Estates and buildings that have really
struggling with storage space then you
know we're more than happy to have
conversations with residents about how
we might develop some new storage
options for them and a good example of
that is in Tomlin Drive where we've
recently demolished garages and we're
proposing
um a subject to planning obviously new
homes there is potentially the option to
include some new purpose-built storage
for residents if they want that and
we'll be Consulting about that so I
think we are very aware that for some of
our residents in some of our blocks uh
storage particularly for large items it
is a problem and if we can find
Solutions we will
thank you very much
any further points for members
in that case we are asked to note these
and we all thank you for the work that's
been done in producing that for us as we
move now to uh agenda on item number
eight
um it's your team again to bring us
another obviously linked document
towards our housing stock in the plant
and how we're looking after these things
servicing standards repairs and lettings
thank you very much selling
thank you
um so the service standards are a set of
commitments to our residents they give
information about the level of service
they can expect from us and they also
guide our offices on the level of
service they should be providing
residents were involved in the
development of these standards to
varying degrees
the repair service standard describes
the service that is delivered by our
partnering contractors mirz and Gasco it
gives information to our residents about
what to expect from our repair service
for example the different ways in which
they can report to repair how long
different categories of pet repairs will
take to be carried out how an
appointment will be made what to expect
from a contract when they come to their
home and how we monitor the service
much of this standard is dictated by the
contracts that we have in place however
we did consult the ttlg on the mayor's
customer pledge this document sets out
the standard of behavior for operatives
and call center staff and as a result of
the feedback from the ttlg further
training was put in place for mayor's
call center staff
the letting standard tells residents
what they can expect when they first
move into one of our homes it lets them
know that they will what will happen
when they sign a tenancy agreement what
information they will receive and to
what standard they expect their new home
to be and when they move in
to inform Miss sand standard we have
surveyed all new tenants for the
previous six months we wanted to learn
from their experience and find out what
was important to them when moving in
a message that came through to us loud
and clear was regarding the quality of
information that we give to new tenants
and this has prompted the development of
a new Resident handbook thank you
very much members do you have any
questions
consulated and then councilor Boyd
please
um very brief I would simply like to
support these policies I recommend the
officers and the Tenant and leaseholder
group in their contributions and
assessments of the policies they have
been written well and comprehensively
and set out rights and responsibilities
clearly thank you
thank you very much councilor Boyd
thank you chair just a quick question
obviously I have seen this document
before in one of the CAG groups I think
I raised this question at that time so
it's almost a little bit don't panic
Sally
um so it's almost a little bit more of a
follow-up uh really but obviously where
it mentions
um floors and doors and underneath that
um carpet will will have been removed
and flaws prepared for you to install I
remember last time raising it is that
actually that kind of
um counteracts our aim to insulating
homes by removing all the carpet and and
also carpets quite expensive so for
residents to be able to afford that it's
going to be quite tricky I know you said
that there's some grants available
um but my follow-up to it would be is
there no way that rather than just
removing all the carpet if there's a
decent carpet they're already that we
cannot just keep it in place give it a
clean surely that's more cost effective
for the residents and also for us to
actually help with
um our energy emissions
foreign
yes so so following that meeting I did
take that away and we did consider that
the reasons that carpets are removed is
because in most of the homes that we get
back the carpets are not in a condition
that we would be able to re-let with
them
um they not only are they even very poor
petition very dirty quite often there
are parasites or pests within the
carpets as well and days are unseen
from previous experience we found that
not not here because we remove all the
carpets but where carpets have been left
down new residents will move in they'll
move all their Furniture in and then
find that they've been Infested by fleas
or bed bugs that haven't been detected
at void stage and then they have to
dispose of all their Furniture the
carpets and start all over again it's
for that reason that we do remove all
the carpets and that decision to keep
that in place has has remained although
we did consider it highly
um what we do do is for all new
residents is they get a call from our
rent team and they will see how they are
settling into their new home make sure
they've applied for their benefits that
they're entitled to if they are
struggling to afford carpets they'll get
a referral to our financial welfare
benefits
team and they will assist them with
providing a grant for new carpets
thank you very much
thank you very much we are asked to note
the reports and from here they I mean
it's good to get a mention I think from
one of the cabinet advisory groups is
actually in one of the reports so it's
been there and it's going on from here
uh to to cabinet so thank you very much
for that
item number nine then is a review of our
work program for
2022-23
members we are always asked if we have
any ideas for topics that we might like
uh covered in our work program
um it's probably a good time for me just
to mention that the presentation we were
due to be given this evening which was
replaced by the manston uh issue will be
coming to us at the beginning and early
part of the new year so we're still
gonna and if you remember that's the a
presentation from the leader about the
efficacy of the cabinet advisory groups
whether or not they've had an impact or
enabled people to get a broader
understanding of of how uh the the the
the council is being run and decisions
are being made on a wider note so I just
throw that one in there it hasn't been
scrapped with a scratched we are going
to get that briefing from the lead at
the beginning of the year were there any
other suggestions that members wish to
make
uh forward plan
I didn't see it it's countless I'm
really sorry
um sorry um could you remind me have we
invited councilor cup to speak to us
about toilets before
um
it was part of the coastal review
but public toilets
foreign
that's right we
what a lovely idea I'm sure he'll be
delighted
um
um so could could we make a note to do
that do you think could we ask
Ed
if members would like us to write to
council to ask him for that can we have
a nod of approval yeah yeah thank you
very much for that council at least
we'll do that what is this
I can say and the specific issue you'd
like him to address uh the strategy
going forward if if we're able to
replace any you know refurb what what
what's our plan basically for the next
couple years
councilwin having wandered around my
world I've got about five roads left to
do to look at the state of our the
condition of not only our highways but
also the parking issues we have
particularly along the coastal strip I
know we're still waiting for this
parking review to come by councilor
Saunders but I just am perplexed by the
enforcement of uh
various types of vehicles on our road so
I don't know whether we can look at
parking enforcement I'm particularly
perplexed about Laura Builders vans that
seem to have some sort of voucher which
means they can park wherever they want
for as long as they want blocking our
roads I'm on a bit of a mission actually
but I I do think parking needs a massive
review as as does our highways and I do
understand that it's a very complicated
issue because some of that
responsibility sits with KCC
some of it sits with us I
remarking double yellow line sits with
us
emptying drains these kcc's but there's
a huge issue raft of issues I've got a
24-page
H hip that I've done on my own Ward
which is which is and when the key issue
for residents is one safety two parking
we don't have enough Crossing points so
I don't know whether that can be brought
here or whether we wait for that parking
review or somebody could nudge the
parking review
um people wouldn't have heard me thank
you very much for that we can ask for an
update on the parking enforcement
strategy
yes parking review and enforcement
strategy okay
we'll do that members thank you very
much
um
agenda item number 10 then is our
forward plan and exempt cabinet report
list
um do members have any comments they
wish to make about the list as we have
it
if not we are asked to note the report
members thank you very much it is nine